précisément de ces dernières frappes les
agences de presse nous parle de drone
kamikaze iranien d'où cette nécessité
pour les Ukrainiennes recevoir un
armement spécifique pour se protéger oui
alors dans un premier temps qu'est-ce
qui se passe sur le territoire ukrainien
que depuis en fait l'attaque du pont de
Caire je suis en Crimée là j'allais dire
les représailles russes ont été de
cibler tout le territoire ukrainien et
de le cibler avec soit des missiles soit
avec des drones les drones au départ les
Russes ont manqué on se souvient du
début de l'attaque il y en avait du côté
ukrainien qui était fourni par la
Turquie mais il y en avait pas du côté
russe et en fait à un moment donné ils
ont demandé à ce que les Iraniens leur
en fournissent les Iraniens ils
fabriquent des plus petits drones qui
sont des drones qui sont des drones
kamikazes c'est-à-dire que vous les
envoyez d'un endroit et puis ensuite ils
ont un rayon d'action qui reste assez
important mais qui n'est pas immense et
donc derrière ils vont taper sur les
cibles et ils vont exploser donc du coup
ça fait des dégâts on a vu effectivement
cela arrivait dans le bon bas ça fait
des des percées sur l'armée
ukrainienne mais comme c'était à
l'intérieur des combats on voyait pas
forcément clairement ce qui s'est mis en
place là depuis qu'on est dans la phase
représailles on a soit des missiles qui
ont effectivement une distance plus
importante soit des drones qui sont
envoyés et on voit clairement que la
Russie cible les endroits plus
stratégiques militairement c'est-à-dire
par exemple des centrales qu'elle soit
thermique ou qu'elle soit électrique et
annonce même fait du côté ukrainien
aujourd'hui c'est que de dire qu'ils ont
30% de leur site qui sont équipés
justement pour faire de l'électricité
qui aujourd'hui sont à terre donc ça
fait partie de ce que cible c'est drone
de ce que cible ses missiles ainsi que
des noeuds ferrés ou routiers voilà d'où
cette nécessité exprimée répétée même
par les autorités ukrainiennes de
recevoir un soutien militaire important
on parle notamment de la protection du
ciel craignant oui c'est ça c'est
comment est-ce qu'on met en place une
défense solaire ce qui est compliqué
c'est qu'on n'est pas en train de parler
d'un petit endroit on est en train de
parler d'un pays comme l'Ukraine qui est
très grand et qu'on voit que par exemple
les frappe qui sont en provenance de
Moscou elles touchent aussi bien la
région je dirais La Clusaz c'est-à-dire
le tomba c'est et au dessin mais elles
vont passer par Kef et elles vont
jusqu'à live donc si vous voulez mettre
un parapluie de protection là sur un
pays comme ça c'est un quasiment
impossible vous pouvez le faire sur un
petit état quand vous êtes Israël que
vous avez le Dôme de fer face à des
roquettes ou des missiles qui sont
lancées de l'autre côté de la frontière
mais quand vous avez cette taille là
c'est quasiment impossible donc ce que
demande aujourd'hui à les Ukrainiens
c'est cette capacité d'armement là cette
capacité d'armement là elle est promise
par l'Allemagne par les Américains par
la France par exemple ou même des
missiles par les Pays-Bas mais
simplement elle est très difficile à
acheminer l'Allemagne vient à cheminer
un système iris qu'elle met à
disposition ils en ont promis quatre les
Américains ont promis effectivement 8
systèmes mais à il y en aura que 6 qui
pourront arriver en 2023 parce que c'est
très long à mettre en place ces coûteux
à fabriquer ce sont des systèmes plus
complexes donc la délivrance n'est pas
immédiate et la France a dit qu'elle
allait annoncer qu'elle allait mettre
des crottes qui sont aussi un système
effectivement que nous avons parce que
la France n'est pas et on n'a pas
énormément en fait ce domicile de cette
accabila donc on donne des crottes qui
est un vieux système et qui reste assez
opérant et on voit que la grande
difficulté aujourd'hui c'est que vous
avez en fait des couvertures qui sont
des missiles qui eux frappent sur un
rayon de grosso modo 25 30 40 km on
n'est pas du tout sur les ce qu'on fait
de plus performants quand on parle par
exemple des S400 non ce sont de télé
Turcs qui sont des systèmes anti-admissi
justement mais qui ont un rayon de 250
300 km donc on se retrouve sur plutôt
des protections de courtes ou moyenne
portée c'est pas tout à fait ce
qu'attendre des Ukrainiens mais
concrètement on n'a pas grand chose
d'autre à donner parce que vous m'avez
entendu ça coûte cher on en a pas à
disposition et donc il faut aussi aller
les chercher et les dire on aura bien
compris c'est de donner sans s'affaiblir